welcome to this video playing Dagoberto
de gilberto I know her from her from
Spain John the scandal and she Goran
stuff is some are very popular i know
people play it
yeah it's not so bad for black
definitely definitely playable I just
play a normal developing I have a tick
with the bishop yogi can take you
forward I should get it back um Queen a
4-1 yeah maybe and maybe it's got night
before after Queen a phone I can also
just take him and then play Queenie for
getting the porn back
hmm
yeah even if it takes between 3-6 I will
always gathered here or not fatigue here
maybe maybe Bishop before is annoying
with Roxy to be impossible I can I can
go back to see form immediately ok guess
I should cancel
how black is reflective pieces are in
the sea poorness a bit weak but it
shouldn't be the end of the world yeah
should I do maybe Ruby 12 hour to get
rid of the rook okay he's going for
exchanges
we are taking rupee one rupee hate this
leads to nothing maybe maybe a draw end
game at best okay Quinn back Quinn a 6
channel just want to try keep a little
bit of fight on the board on e5 I
intended to play d5 ok it's just maybe I
could have taken a seven actually why
not I calendar but now yeah why not so
big big problem don't see it maybe you
couldn't defend it anyway
check
check to hear to e4 I a some
centralizing or to f3 actually may be
here provoking g6 and then getting the
night into the game 92 e for trying to
win a bit of time on the Kings side so
at the end I get to to keep the porn
here 94 maybe can get to get to g5 here
sneeze got no check right so we must
probably retreat now Queen back
yeah I want to keep the Queen busy here
on the Kings side trying to gain some
ground here at the end get the ape on
going and one know what to see what is
your calculating isn't he just forced
you to go back wow I cannot just second
just take a success also and of course
queen bee 727 he might have quindi one
okay come on let's keep it simple just
scrap this a night f form Sam should be
very good
Queen D 51 yeah I guess come the Queen
trade should be totally sufficient and
Queen f7 is a big threat of course oh I
can give the check here but check okay
let's see how do I actually win it King
over to c6 probably
interesting takes
every g4g for jeff g fine why you should
win yeah the king and porn porn and
games very easy here I can check and
also take the bishop check for what's
the easiest mg3 mg3 d5 be four check
check now winning the the g pawns black
resigns yeah I'm not not quite sure
where things went wrong for black he was
certainly ok here blackest is very
active so yeah night ok that computer
gives black a good game with the ship
takes and Queen g5 justing Queen g5
probably because castles castles 94 is
winning for black which I find
remarkable I mean that black is ok a
queen h 5 ER this is very dangerous hmm
minus 9y a queen age 5 and there is also
of course f21 the pressure so i don't
have an easy move with def porn over
there look oh this means that Queen g5
is very very strong Queen poor that's it
sets very difficult compounds to play
night d 1 which clearly shows there's
something wrong or Queenie for all minus
0.8 0.9 yeah probably I shouldn't have
taken on c6 then I mean here should be
it should be equal rook b6 here I don't
know this is a bit mysterious everything
b6 is given by the computer why not here
Quincy 6 intending this ok equal a black
ass sir Black is active but here he
really is just a pawn down and he went
for this rather I don't know quite
willingly here it's a it's really a
question if black can survive it in any
way I but hey Musti must retreat the
Queen I mean f5 is losing Queen B seven
assists even strong i have i had the
suspicion but i didn't want to screw up
and does this keeps a baguette with with
easy game Queen B 7s however better me I
wasn't totally sure jess is in fact
check leading to a maid I for Gaia this
is this is cute ok so here here 9f form
25 yeah I always make a plate that the
keep it simple method which is neither
not a bad way to go about it in an end
go okay i was a bit luckier he could
have gotten an excellent position in the
opening thanks for watching